our david pakman show subreddit is just
doing so well I don't I was looking for
some kind of a more descriptive
vocabulary but it's just doing
incredibly well we're approaching 6,000
of our viewers and listeners subscribed
at david pakman.com slash read it
regularly really great discussions and
conversations about politics about the
show suggestions for guests and stories
I noticed this morning that there was a
question posed on the subreddit which
asked should David do more videos on
feminism which I find interesting and as
many in the audience know I am both
someone who believes in the principles
the basic tenets of feminism and yet
have been critical of some of the more
recent developments some of the more
sort of extreme flavors of feminism that
have developed but of course I do
consider myself someone who believes in
the importance of a Galit arianism and
and basic feminism however it's a topic
I can't touch without pissing off a lot
of people and it's sort of like when we
talk about circumcision or when I talk
about the israeli-palestinian conflict
it's one of those were like 10% of the
audience just appreciates me discussing
it in a sort of even-handed way and the
other 90% is either furious at what I
said or furious at what I didn't say but
listen we talked about feminism on the
program I'm not shying away from it and
I don't know should I be doing more
videos on feminism I'm not sure I'll put
it to the audience to give me feedback
about that also on our subreddit let's
play a game who's next this is like a
cabinet firing bingo trump
administration bingo where people are
voting for who they think is gonna go
next from Trump's cabinet I'm preparing
myself for just a knodel cabinet
shakedown I think that there could be
major major changes here we're hearing
about HR McMaster who is as National
Security Advisor is not actually a
cabinet member but certainly a close
aide to Trump the White House is
reportedly furious about how Betsy DeVos
Secretary of Education totally bungled a
couple of recent interviews one on 60
minutes one on NBC News she could be on
the chopping block chief of staff John
Kelly again chief of staff are not on
the cabinet but there's constant
discussion about whether he's gonna go
Jeff Sessions is reportedly maybe going
to get fired and also maybe going to
fire Andrew McCabe I wouldn't know who
to guess I still think Kushner needs to
go and again he's not a cabinet member
by any means Jeff Sessions one is a
little bit tricky because as Trump's
attorney general you maybe get into a
some obstruction of justice concerns by
firing him by firing him maybe Muller
would look into that trying to obstruct
the Russia investigation yeah I even
though our sessions is recused on it but
still that doesn't feel related he's
still related and sessions can make
decisions that would impact that
investigation based on who he hires or
fires reenter I'm gonna go with HR
McMaster yeah I think he's going I think
he's going very very soon so anyway you
can vote on that if you check out that
thread also from the david pakman show
subreddit a compliments about the
scientology interviews that have been
done and that we should do more of these
or not we've been thinking of doing sort
of a scientology related material at
this point between interviewing al ron
Hubbard's grandson or great-grandson I
forget now Jamie DeWolf we've
interviewed a number of high-level
Scientologists we've interviewed Sea Org
Scientologists we could do like almost a
mini documentary on Scientology based
around our interviews alone and I think
SIA it's it's a it's a fascinating cult
but I don't want to spend more time on
it than it deserves either in the end I
think they have under a hundred thousand
members or some good book Tom Cruise I
think that'll be a little short oh sure
I don't see that happening anytime soon
and lastly from the david pakman show
subreddit perpetual gate i am being
called out for using the wrong word i
used the word perpetrate when I should
have said perpetuate I do know the
difference between these two so I
appreciate the grammatical correction I
think it was probably a verbal slip of
verbal typos where I had what some might
call a brain fart or a glitch of some
kind a neuron fired or didn't fire based
on I guess what your perspective on that
is but listen I do know the difference
between perpetrate and perpetual
and I will make every effort to
perpetuate a strong English grammar
ethic on the program anyway sign up free
discuss politics and the show with other
viewers at david pakman.com slash read
it